hey it's tech Tuesday and today I'm
answering a question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys Shelli
babe who asked is HootSuite a free
service so Shelley babe I'm a huge food
sweet fan here is my HootSuite I use it
mostly just for Twitter with a little
bit of my personal and my business
Facebook accounts and I used to track my
sent tweets various lists I look at this
every single day every single day I've
set it up so that it's been super
helpful and helped me manage my accounts
but is it free so the answer is kind of
HootSuite works on a freemium model so
you get a lot for free and then if you
want upgrades then you have to pay for
them so here's the page it talks about
the plane it's hootsuite.com slash plans
now I don't work for her - HootSuite or
make any money off of it I'm just a
happy customer and for years I was on
the free plan this is the free plan you
can get up to 3 social profiles for free
so you saw that I use my my Twitter
account my personal Facebook and my
business Facebook those are three
although really if there's said only up
to one I'd still be on the free plan and
just use it for Twitter and you get a
little bit of basic features but most of
the benefits that I'd like using
HootSuite for you can get in the free
package the only reason why I went pro
so I'm on this plane now it's 9 bucks a
month or $8.99 a month is right where is
message scheduling here basic versus
advanced so this is a difference if you
ever need to schedule your messages you
can go to HootSuite and you can click
schedule you can add a specific tweet at
a certain time and put it whenever you
want right so August 28th at this time
and you will post and you can do that in
the free plan you can do that and it's
super helpful
but if you ever need to send bulk
messages in advance then this bulk
message uploader is only available if
you pay for
and what you can do here is upload a
file it's an excel file that has the
tweets you want to get out at their
whatever time and who seek we'll send it
up at those times this I needed to use
because I do tweet chats and every month
they do a tweet chat and we're talking
about small business issues and people
ask me questions and I have a list of
all the people who are in my previous
tweet chats and they said hey let us
know when the next one's coming out so
you should the day before I'll send a
message to everybody saying hey tomorrow
is the tweet chat day and to schedule
them in one by one by one by one is too
time-consuming and so they'll be able to
do it all from an excel file and
uploaded the HootSuite for me is worth
nine bucks a month but that's the only
reason I'm on the pro version so I would
say take a spin with it get started do
the free version there's so many
powerful features that you can use there
and if you have questions about it let
me know and I can help you out maybe
make another video for you and then if
you discover that you need more than
three profiles or you really need to do
you know you need more analytics or you
want to add your team to it so they can
manage it for you or you know you need
to do better scheduling like what I just
talked about then you can look at doing
the 899 the plans 810 you have a month
plan and it's a 30-day free trial so you
can check it out but really get started
on the free little super on the free and
it can get you really far you know I I
get tons of comments on Twitter and I'm
almost a power user but Twitter is a big
part of my business and so I was able to
stay on the free plan for a super long
time so if you're just getting started
it's definitely way to set up so it is
kind of free with some cool paid option
upgrades believe for those of you
watching you like the video you can
subscribe to the channel you can support
me if I click on a link in the
description and leave a comment let me
know what you think I love your comments
and make me want to keep doing more
videos for you so thank you and I will
see you soon